the Pentagon has identified the four
Americans killed in Syria this week they
were among at least 20 people who died
in a suicide bombing there the Islamic
state group claimed responsibility for
the attack the Americans were killed in
northern Syria on Wednesday it was the
deadliest assault on US troops in Syria
since American forces went there in 2015
Charlie d'Agata is in Syria with more
Charlie good morning good morning
American and coalition aircraft have
continued to strike Isis targets on the
ground here overnight in support of US
troops and their allies on the ground
here at the same time the terror group
issued a warning saying there'll be more
suicide bombings targeting American
troops here the fourth American killed
in that restaurant bombing has been
identified 27 year-old Kadir Taher a
translator she was killed along with
green beret Jonathan farmer Navy Chief
Petty Officer Shannon Kent and former
navy seals Scott words while Isis may be
fighting for its survival on the
battlefield they still have the ability
to launch counter-attacks now we visited
those frontlines to see for ourselves
local ground forces with u.s. boots
right beside them commanders here are
reluctant to tell us how much longer
what they're calling the final battle
will take but the bombing and manbij
appears to confirm what many fear here
that Isis is already transitioning from
a territorial force to an underground
terror network and it's a tragic
reminder of the lethal threat that Isis
continues to pose as the Trump
administration begins the withdrawal of
2000 US troops here for CBS this morning
Saturday Charlie d'Agata in northern
Syria